hi I'm Kevin I'm shrekt we're in 2010
abstract made a post on the Kanye live
online forum now known as Kanye to the
asking if anyone wanted to form a band
to which over 30 users responded a lot
of people were applied and whoever
replied they got to join the group so it
didn't matter if you were talented or
not
I just wanted to collect a little bunch
of people so we could like spread our
music and random studies and stuff you
were one of the people bro right replied
how many members are in Brockhampton and
who are they
I can never say how many members are in
yeah John look in the camera and say
everyone's name and who yeah we got
Kevin abstract yeah Matt champion I'm da
McLennan Joba Merlin Merlin and
bare-faced as the artists we got wrong
on him Donny Kiko merly
and Jabari man wise the producers behind
the scenes we got Henoch slushee age k
we got - went behind the cameras over
there me John and then we got Rob who's
not here for great though Turkey who do
you think is the most talented member of
Brockhampton Rock what who's asking
talent it was telling me one thing
that's all I think like people could
play instruments and like do all the
extra so I can't do know that I'd vote
like Joba or Karen first roughly yeah is
everybody cool with that
what genre is Brockhampton pop music bro
father Bobby rock came to me next was
the origin of the name Brockhampton was
a street I grew up on in Corpus Christi
Texas seriously Ashlin let's pick up
your voice boys he's so good bro
this actually he runs our Twitter yeah
larnice our grants are to the fans for
being late some sizes maybe only
sometimes you know upload late I love
Brock camera but how doesn't do all
those different voices really ok so he
came from a lot of different places
yeah he was born Grenada he lived in
Connecticut he's gay
too big straight as well they would also
move to Belfast Texas next
how does Brockhampton write in produce
music so quickly because he's gay and
blue Texas come on easy next how does
broad can't remember whose turn it is to
sing during their concerts I'd be on the
end mouthing the words trying to
remember where my part is Merlin always
changes his lyrics onstage I think
people are totally something it's
interesting it's fun but how does
Brockhampton get paid there's about 30
of them RCA actually just cash apps me
and then depending on you know I'm
saying if I feel like you know people
are worthy you know how many One
Direction references this Brockhampton
make a lot of best boy bands just dances
One Direction anybody got Harry Styles
phone number okay I'll call guess I got
the wrong
next one that's it really - how does
broad camp whose new album compared to
this last releases it's our favourite
album it's our favourite love it I like
the overall tone of the new album
because we've experienced new life you
too can someone explain the purpose and
we're meaning behind this video I'm
curious
yes I took a treadmill to the house I
grew up in on Brockhampton Street in
Corpus Christi Texas and I ran on the
treadmill for 10 hours straight that's a
little deep I don't want to say why I
can't say I feel ya can't say why sorry
but for people that don't know what this
is that's what that is I think if you
you know sit down and watch the video
you'll go into different things you
should just watch it and whatever makes
you feel oh this video like GQ videos it
does exactly what you say are we doing
it wrong no you're doing it amazing I'm
just saying like when you say why Oh
like why I don't want to say why don't
say one solo project from all the boys
possibly no I won't allow it
how would you write the album's now Oh
ginger saturation - etc from one section
three I might sound like a complete fake
fan but who on the coverage in a jobber
hug and oh yes it's Joba and then Weston
but Wesson is asleep behind the camera
somebody called waiting west enough last
night
can we come up don't we can just film in
waited oh yeah just film it posted
alright and by captain Paul rod pulled
me to the side he's like yo your solo
album means a lot less you next are
kevin dominic like ever gonna perform
peach if Dom isn't drunk and if I can
remember my lyrics perfect perfect next
the RO melons of Bari date the melons
Ybarra produce literally every track on
the album
Jabari and I produce the bulk of the
album which whose kyouko point of them
they've been new next what's the most
underrated Brockhampton song in your
opinion my answer is bang on saturation
one bank mine is a district on your
deserts thanks ginger about God or
religion and [ __ ] like that
yes reply replied this room Superman
that home y'all think the boys have
their own group shot yeah we have group
chats it's complicated the words when
people don't read the group chat like
hey guys we have to do this this and
that people we never read it away yo we
got a show tomorrow my Bros in the group
chatter but there will be more merch
jobs right if you guys want it I love
making merge so this is GQ Oh
okay get that dog
warmer jumps yes hey if you want this go
to what ginger calm calm next favorite
bright Hampton moment freestyling uh
sway in the morning
[Music]
this crazy ass high note that I've never
heard him do before and like I like
sorry fine
literally the know it was like one of
those things where it just like applied
next standout song from each member we
need to take a moment that's all pot
heads down okay
and when you think of one just pull you
pull your head up look at the camera and
say it when you think [ __ ] boy by dumb
yeah say job on big boy
bare face on Big Boy yeah thanks
next does any the BH members snapchats
are you soon
your approach is there is Joe the
propane well that's it we answered your
questions
we're signing off the internet seriously
[Music]
are we